oh boy are we on the verge of another
conservative comeback
Last Man Standing starring Tim Allen
headed back to TV
Fox is reviving the series which was the
second highest rated comedy on ABC
before it was cancelled after a six
season run a Fox TV executive says the
success of Roseanne's reboot reboot has
emboldened them to bring Alan back but
another Fox exec says he thinks the show
wasn't canceled because of politics in
any case here's a sneak peek at the
reboot this is the best day ever we've
been doing up there on the only ask
questions that you really want the
answers to
I think I'm too affectionate yes that's
the beef everybody has with you there's
only one book you have to follow
word-for-word
the Bible the federal tax code so Greg
he's been a trump supporter all along
and now he's coming back in light of
what happened with Roseanne has been an
astounding success what do you think so
I don't I don't remember his show being
conservative politically and that's I
think what the story is here is that
it's being portrayed as conservative
simply because it's not so annoyingly
liberal right Hollywood is so far left
now just being normal which is what that
show appears to be normal common sense
is now right-wing that's the story and
and Dana now it's interesting because
the people at Roseanne say they're gonna
do more family stuff less politics and
Greg makes the point that show to him
wasn't all that political right I think
that in some ways it's just because of
maybe the way things have been the last
three years we're coming up on the three
years since President Trump went down
the escalator it's like we're seeing
everything through some sort of
political lens when maybe it doesn't
even really have to be that way it could
be that Fox thinks that it can make
money having Tim Allen show back on air
and that's a good business decision it
doesn't necessarily have to do with
politics people really love the show
there was an outcry when it was
cancelled and so I think this is
probably a good business move not
necessarily political one a well
reasoned and well dated I think you'd
love it you know what you know what the
impact on you and me is Jesse what's
that one there
night football is going to be on Fox and
they're going to absolutely use that to
launch their Friday night schedule
including mr. is that right thing that
no what do you think of Tim Allen and do
you think this is about a conservative
resurgence in terms of American media
well I don't know if he was a real
conservative advocate when he was on the
air I know off the air he is but I think
the lights go off and Hollywood said
wait a second there's over 60 million
Republican voters in this country they
all have TVs like Dana said it's a
purely business decision conservative
entertainment does very well
I mean look politics is funny Jon
Stewart does well site live does well
Greg Gutfeld waters world mos tucker
carlson hilarious that's a riot so
there's an appetite for politics and
humor and people for a long time in
hollywood tried to keep down
conservative talent because they were
always supposed to be marginalized and
ridiculed you don't want to have a
conservative voice kind of glamour tries
because you want to try to sideline
those voices but now money talks well so
they have to you know it's like Field of
Dreams right they built in like a maggot
home and they went like if you give him
a place to watch and view like Roseanne
Barr there are viewers out there why
wouldn't you try and capture that part
of you know the market to be quite
honest it makes perfect business sense
to mountains like incredibly talented
the show was very well received I think
it's a very smart business decision I
hope he cooked me we should have him on
the show for a segment one day do you
think already booked on waters world
sorry okay with Sebastian worker
[Applause]
doesn't go with anybody else all right